gentlemen I'm wondering if we can go
back to whether it was growing up in you
know Bay Area or Santa Barbara or even
as far back as the Midwest and you just
think about what story impacted you the
most as children whether it's a TV show
comic book novel and how did it sort of
formed your love for story early on sure
this what I like to think about is the
fact that we didn't have a television in
my house so I went over to the
neighbor's house and every year they
used to broadcast The Wizard of Oz and I
saw the Wizard of Oz when I was very
very young must have been about four or
five years old and everything was good
until we got to the Wicked Witch then
things got a little bit scary so I
bailed I said I can't stay here anymore
I have to go home so I don't know if it
was a traumatic impact but that story
was something that made a huge impact as
a kid and you know I finally got through
watching the movie a little when I was a
little bit older but but I found that
one to be so realistic and terrifying
that it made it a very very deep
impression I used to make cocktails for
Margaret Hamilton and my first
bartending job in New York City way back
in the late seventies how did she like
her martini can't remember what she
drank I just remember how diminutive and
tiny she was and she no longer looked
very scary oh no she was a good tipper
by the way she sat at a table okay for
me I distinctly remember reading Jack
London's call of the wild and tears
streaming out the sides of my eyes at
the end of the book and just the power
of stories and that I wanted to relive
and wanted to stay in that world but
probably a bigger impression was a weird
collection of American history stories
badly illustrated in three tone
colors and I reboard so the presidents
and so that's probably how far back my
love of history started Ron just as a
side note you mentioned briefly not
having a television having to go to a
neighbor's was this out of fear of this
new box or that it seemed to be taking
America down or I wish I could say that
it was that you know important of a
commentary on why we didn't have it but
what happened was the TV broke at a
certain point and then my parents
decided they weren't going to get it
fixed and then we didn't get one for
another like 11 or 12 years my god yeah
so that's that's how that happened okay
because I do remember watching the
Flintstones in the basement with TV
dinners but that was you know a long
time ago interesting we were without a
television as well and I was born when
my father was in medical school and I
don't think we had one when we moved to
New Hampshire and I also remember the
Wizard of Oz being the first thing I was
aware of and again I saw it at a
neighbor's house it got a Bobbie sax
from Boston and made a big impression on
me but my dad never really cared about
movies or entertainment I don't think he
had grown up with a minute when we moved
to Santa Barbara we got the local
channel with the TV antenna and and that
was it and and we had a black-and-white
TV for years and so yeah I was a late
bloomer as well getting to getting to
the movies interesting I know the two of
you met at Carnegie Mellon I think I
want to just go back quickly actually
step ahead I know Ron you were a PA on
the Godfather three that is true
so was that an ambition of yours to be
in the film industry I know you both
receive what I'm sure I mean my
background is
that I started out as an actor and I did
too started out as a kid basically as an
actor from a pretty early age and the
way that I got involved with The
Godfather was that not too long out of
college I had auditioned for the movie
called The Outsiders and befriended one
of the producers of that film I didn't
get in the movie but I stayed in touch
with him
and I remember that I was on a
construction job and very frustrated I
was like putting up sheetrock or
something and I called his office in LA
and they said well he's not here right
now he's in Italy and I said oh is there
any way that I could get that number and
they said sure and they gave me the
number I called him in Italy and I said
you know are you doing anything right
now and he said well we're about to come
to New York and we're shooting Godfather
3 right now and I said oh great and then
it turned out I was laid off my my
construction job the very week that they
came into town so I said I'll I'll do
anything to work on the Godfather and so
I ended up doing extra work and also
assisting the producer and it was a
great time Wow and I understand you were
on a Larry Fessenden film one of his
first yeah Larry and I were good friends
we met through a playwright who had
written the script of his of his senior
film at NYU
Evan McHale a guy that Ron and I went to
college with at Carnegie Mellon and I
played a fifty-year-old glassmerchant
alcoholic you know I was 25 our film
which both Larry and I are very proud of
I don't know if anybody else likes it
but but yeah we've been friends for a
long time and I yeah I've done several
things with Larry so going back to
Carnegie Mellon both of you had
aspirations to be an actor or to be
actors or you felt that maybe one day
you would also make films I I really
wanted to be a stage actor
they wanted to be a Shakespearean actor
and but yeah I moved to New York and I
really spent a decade going to art house
movies and seeing classic cinema and
foreign cinema particularly French and
Japanese and realized my real love was
there but since I loved history and I
got a little frustrated living in New
York and I very much got into Western
history and I saw three documentaries
that really turned my head around one
was Ken Burns's Civil War one was Ross
McElwee 'he's Sherman's march which was
supposed to be this historical story
about sherman smarts through through the
south that his girlfriend leaves him
when he starts making the film and he
tries to date women following Sherman's
trail it's great laughs yeah and then
David Peplow I think his name is rot J
robert Oppenheimer the day after Trinity
about the making of the atomic bomb and
I saw that at Joe Papps Public Theatre
and it just it just made such an
impression on me not only did a live to
read history but the way it could be
laid out on film was very impressive
yeah yeah so for me in terms of Carnegie
Mellon I was a young actor as I
mentioned and I knew that CMU was one of
the premier schools to train at that and
Julliard I applied for both I actually
got into both but I ended up going to
Carnegie Mellon and it was an amazing
period of time there at Carnegie because
we had our class was particularly strong
and there were some really great people
there Holly Hunter was in our class and
John Wells was around and cherry Jones
was around so these were just amazing
people that were with us and in terms of
film I had done a little bit of
television before
Carnegie as an actor but I always wanted
to I always had an interest in writing
so I'd written some plays and
like that and I remember that I actually
I did write a play that at Carnegie and
then I also made my first film at
Carnegie I and this was completely
outside of the curriculum this was
completely self-motivated and it was
super 8 and I recently read a little bit
about what was going on at the time
because I had forgotten all about it but
um you know it was like I don't know a
couple hundred dollars budget and and
shot it with with friends from class and
we edit it over like a 24 hour period I
remember on and wuzzle super 8
you know editing machines and then the
the audio was on a separate system
completely out of sync even though we
recorded it at the time that we shot it
there was no way to put the picture and
the sound together and then we had one
screening that we played the audio on a
separate sound system and hopefully it
lined up but it was probably out of sync
so it was it was pretty fun but that was
my first filmmaking experience and yeah
I really enjoyed it
going back to Sherman's march for a
moment I mean that is what's a
three-hour film isn't it or close to it
it could be I can't remember now yeah
yeah it certainly could be it's been a
few years I've seen it but I think that
even even when he made it at that time
it's pretty similar to what filmmakers
go through today and you know family
pressure and different things and I
highly recommend anybody to see it is
it's even though it's an older film it's
it's pretty representative of what I
would think it still still holds up I'm
actually overdue to see it again yeah
yeah I kind of want to see it again -
Ron is this your passion to go to old
bookstores or to peruse bookstores and
and look at different titles or you just
happen to stumble upon marks it was
purely happenstance and this was not I
mean this was like a modern-day
bookstore and it was yeah I was just in
in a bookstore and I was browsing books
and
and I was a stack of new titles on a
table and I was some for some reason I
was attracted to go look at this new
stack of books that had come in and I
saw a photograph that I'd never seen
before on the cover of one of the books
but I recognized one of the people in
the photograph was my grandfather I mean
I knew his face right away even though
he was like 19 or 20 in the picture and
then the title of the book was
millionaires unit and I said oh wait I
know what that is because the I knew
about the story of the first Yale unit
from my family but I did not know the
details that Marc Wortman laid out in
his book so brilliantly and so was a it
was a really happy discovery and sort of
started the whole catalyst of getting
the documentary going so you had known
from your family that you know he had
flown and different things like that but
did you know that a book had been made I
did not know that Marc's book was in the
works or was being published back in the
1920s the Davison family who were the
original sponsors of the Yale unit had a
book published a two-volume book
published and that was distributed
throughout the United States to
libraries that chronicled the history of
the Yale unit with their letters and
journals and photos so there was a lot
of material in that but I had not spent
much time looking at that at all and it
wasn't really until marks book came
along that that I really learned the
details so then at what point did you
contact Derek and say should we make
this film should we devote over seven
years of our lives to making this movie
and all the interesting things that I'm
sure happened right I mean I'll tell
part of the story and Derek can tell
part of the story too for me was you
know I read read the book and and loved
it because I felt it like put me like
right next to my grandfather back in
1916 as he was going through all these
experiences that's how well the book was
written
one of those types of books where you
just feel you're there and Marc Wortman
I got in touch with him he invited me to
a panel in New York and I asked him the
first question I had for Marc was is
anyone making a documentary about this
book because I think it's an amazing
story I'd love to see it and Marc said
no not to my knowledge no one's making a
documentary and I said oh so that sort
of put the put the bug in my bonnet as
it were to make the film and then I
approached Derek about it but the thing
that really sold me on Derek I knew that
he was a documentary filmmaker and had
the experience you know of making
documentary films but I went over to his
apartment one day and there were all
these old photographs on the wall like I
didn't know who these people were but
there were there were old paintings and
old photographs and I go yeah this is
the guy this guy loves history he loves
these old pictures he'll be perfect for
this but it wasn't a quick sale and I
let Derek pick up on that part of the
story yeah I just sort of put the book
on the my huge stack of reading lists
and thought I'll get to it eventually
and Ron would bug me about it and
finally I read it and he also bought me
a copy of the two-volume history from
1925 and I read that and I had several
other irons in the fire of projects that
I wanted to do and but I didn't have a
partner you know these were all things
that I was doing on my own and and I
thought maybe it would be a good thing
to work with somebody else and I looked
at it as a rather small film to begin
with Ron said he was going out to the
Yale Club for this talk and he met some
of the families and he said they have
collections of photographs that nobody
has seen before and I thought well maybe
we can get a little money together and
we can make sort of a family film using
these little photographs and give it to
all the families of the first yell unit
members and let's see what our Chi Ville
material is out there and and I think my
biggest concern was figuring on how the
story the first Yale unit fit into World
War one and fit into US Naval Aviation
which was just minutes infant stage
and I and then we got going and the
project look a little bigger and I sort
of thought now this will take maybe two
and a half years
it'll cost maybe three hundred and fifty
thousand dollars and we got our initial
grant for twenty five thousand dollars
and we went out to the old Rhinebeck
aerodrome which is up in the Hudson
River Valley and they put on shows all
summer and I can't remember what time of
year it was was it spring were they just
starting their season yeah and it was
rather rainy you know we had one day
booked for this thing and I think we had
a little bit of insurance but anyway it
was a spectacular day and they they
could not fly their sock with camel
unfortunately but they flew their other
planes and we had a variety of skies
with Sun with clouds with some rain and
really had a terrific day and came home
with some some airplane footage which we
then started editing into little
sections of the film which we would show
around and try and get people interested
in our project so do you think this is
the documentarians dilemma you you just
you have an idea you say well I have all
these other irons in the fire but this
sounds great and it becomes something
much bigger than you initially planned
do you think that's a common thing I
don't think it's a dilemma and I think
that's really part of the the artistic
and creative process of putting the film
together and I've spoken to I know of
many documentary filmmakers that have
started out with a kernel of an idea and
watch that idea change and grow I know
Steve James who did who dreams talked
about this he was going to make a little
film with his little brother he was a
big brother to this guy and it turned
into rather an epic film about the
justice system and child rearing and
education and it was really something
and he said but you know I had conceived
of it as something completely different
and there were several stages in the
millionaire's unit where the project
just kept growing and and then in the
end it was really about airplanes and
where are we going to get them how were
we going to shoot them and
and we really thought that along with
telling the very human and emotional
story through these guys letters that if
we could also tell the story about what
it took to fly those planes those would
be the two key things that would really
engage the audience right okay so not a
dilemma in a negative sense it's more
more sort of a or a challenge okay right
good way to look at it I know part of
the film especially in the beginning you
talk about these young men and they were
men of privilege and that there was with
privilege comes a great sort of
responsibility to either rise up or to
give back for what they've been given
and I know that's one of your sort of
tag lines on the website for the film
I'm curious how that works into
filmmaking because you say privilege
duty and sacrifice that's kind of a line
that you have on your website how do you
filmmakers stack up against that
challenge or responsibility if someone's
fortunate enough to make a film whether
they've been given grants or they have
investors how does that sort of weave
into the filmmakers experience well for
me the idea of you know sacrifice having
to do with filmmaking it really wasn't
so much that I often felt that you know
the the gentleman that we were telling
the story about were so dedicated to
their cause and their cause was just you
know to serve their country and do what
they could to you know protect the
United States and to do that they were
willing to put this airforce little
airforce together and and and and to
join the military when when they felt
that their country needed them and I was
never really one to serve the country in
that way I was not really interested in
joining the military myself but I felt
that this story was very important to
get out there so in terms of you know my
own service as it were I feel like
telling this story and and allowing
people to understand
and who these young men were and what
drove them is something that's worth
getting out there and making the
sacrifice to make happen so in that
regard I think a filmmaker often times
will be you know find something that
they feel very strongly about them that
they want to convey to an audience and
and you know it's worth making the
sacrifice to make that happen I was a
little worried about this story early on
just because it was about these most of
them very wealthy privileged guys and of
course you want to cast sort of a wide
net to bring in as much interest as
possible in making a film and I was
worried that maybe people can relate to
them enough and trying to talk about you
know that wealthy blueblood Society from
back then which really did rule America
and and I thought it might be that it
might exclude a lot of potential
audience people but the story really was
about the individual initiative of these
guys rising to the occasion of learning
to fly supporting their friends and then
joining the war effort and you could see
in the story and from reading their
letters that a good number of them got
in over their heads and one guy in
particular really was not meant to fly
was not capable at all but the idea of
letting down his friends and of opting
out of the unit just was unthinkable to
him and he would really rather die than
not try to make the sacrifices that he
saw his friends making and and and
that's what happened as a filmmaker
again it comes back to history not just
the fact that I love history but that I
feel like history really grounds us as a
society and helps people understand who
they are and what their responsibilities
are and I feel like a lot of people in
America just don't pay attention to
things
like that so if you can make a film an
historical film that really lives that
that has a personal story as well as the
context of big movement movements in in
the world if you can make that live on
film I think that's a job well done so
that was really the the motivating thing
for me in the story I thought it was
interesting that because it also showed
about the pressures to sort of fit in
and any young person feels those
pressures you feel them when you're in
your 40s but especially then in that
situation and the one gentleman who was
not invited to the secret society and
how that ended up really changing him
and and putting sort of a chip on his
shoulder but maybe for the better
because he was very driven from that
point so I thought that was really an
interesting part to the film because so
much of this was these men were heralded
but then there was the one that was sort
of the outcast and I thought that was
actually very interesting yeah I wanted
to actually know more about him you know
in that sense but yeah the black sheep
the black sheep you know because really
made really made something of his his
short life it's really moving yeah yeah
well there there are two very good
collections of letters that he wrote
before he died at 24 when to his fiancee
and they were discovered by one of the
historians that we interview in the film
he was having dinner with this woman and
she said well you know my grandmother
she has all these letters from this
world war one aviator you might be
interested and they were Kenny McLeish
his letters that were under her
grandmother's bed and she didn't marry
for 12 years after Kenny died and stayed
I think was was in love with them all
her life and and so Jeffrey found these
letters and he published them through
the Navy press in the early 70s and and
they make quite an impression
Kenny McLeish who is the great-uncle of
our narrator the actor Bruce Dern which
was fun we were recording Bruce for his
narration and on his phone he brought up
a photograph of the house in which he
grew up and it was a huge house he came
from a very wealthy family he was
actually excommunicated from
family for becoming an actor but but he
grew up in the same mansion and in the
same bedroom as Kenny McLeish there were
these four turrets on the house and he
had he had one of them and that had been
Kenny McLeish his bedroom a hundred
years earlier there fifty years before
Bruce at what point did you reach out to
Bruce turn to become a narrator how did
this all take place well we got to meet
Bruce Dern through one of our advisers
on the film a producer named Fred ruse
who was the guy from The Godfather and
he told us that Bruce was related to one
of the characters in our story we did
not know that at that time I don't know
how Fred knew that I don't know why he
would know such an obscure thing but I
didn't know either
I think he knew it because I believe
Bruce's middle name is McLeish oh right
yeah I think so but even then it's not
like Kenny McLeish is a is a household
name right Archibald Kenny McLeish his
older brother was Archibald MacLeish the
poet laureate and and you know a very
well-known writer in America in fact
there's a great story you know Bruce was
ousted from his family and the only one
he was in touch with was Archibald
MacLeish because Archibald wrote a verse
play called JB that Elia Kazan directed
on Broadway and at the time Elia Kazan
had six actors under contract it was
Bruce Dern Geraldine page Rip Torn Pat
Hingle and I can't remember the other
one but you know so he was reunited with
with Archie and he would have dinner
with his uncle
quite often his uncle would catch him up
on on family family business yeah but
Bruce came and saw one of our rough cuts
of the film and he was really impressed
with the movie he was like this is great
actually he turned to us and he said
some about
I remember he commented to do was
somebody that's been has this been
submitted to the Oscars yet we were like
we didn't even have any flying footage
in it yet or not the stuff that we got
in New Zealand I mean it was it was a
very rough cut but yeah they were so he
was and then later on after we saw that
rough cut then later on when we were
casting for our narrator his name was on
the list and after the whole process of
finding someone he ended up being the
person who was available and interested
and and did the job for us so that was
we weren't amazing hoping he was going
to do it for free or at a discount
because he loved the story but his his
agent drove a very hard bargain
but it was worth it yeah absolutely
I'm wondering with the $25,000 initial
grant when did you realize you needed
more and then how did you end up
consuming or not consuming scuse me how
did you end up getting more funding what
was your process well we we knew we
needed more and we got to know two
grandsons of the first year unit members
Harry Davison in Manhattan and Mike
Davis in Atlanta they're cousins and
share a grandfather true be Davison and
we asked them to be on our fundraising
committee and for I think three and a
half years every Thursday morning at 6
a.m. West Coast time we would talk to
them about you know people they knew
foundations they might be aware of to
raise money and we wrote a lot of
letters and Ron and I we'd go to these
coasts to interview people and do
production and film planes or whatever
we do and then we'd go to New York and
we'd show what we had at the Dolby
screening room there and try to get
people to write checks for us and you
know we'd get $100 here $100 there and
it just it just really wasn't doing it
but Ron started writing a quarterly
newsletter and we started collecting
email addresses and sending this out and
letting them know it was going and
gradually it got out to
more and more foundations we we learned
that there was a level of of money and
foundations that you don't really hear
about but but that wealthy families you
know have to give away X amount of money
every year for for tax purposes and so
there were people that had some relation
to the story whether it was through Yale
whether it was through the Navy or
whether they just wanted to hear a
patriotic see a patriotic story being
told and then and we kept trying for a
corporate sponsor we we worked on JP
Morgan for for over two years because
originally Truby Davison young guy who
founded the unit his father was JP
Morgan's business partner and JP Morgan
had given the fur seal unit $100,000 to
get started and buy airplanes and so we
knew some people working at Morgan and
we went to them and said we'd like the
same amount of money adjusted for
inflation and we were asking for
$200,000 but all that time we were
working on every week in the news there
just be horrible reports about their
corporate behavior and Jamie Dimon and
they've done this and they've done that
and and but you know what we still
wanted the money we still kept trying to
get it and the end it fell through and
and I think sort of out of embarrassment
and kindness they gave us $25,000 which
which helped but in the end our
corporate sponsor was FedEx and we had
been wanting to go to them for a long
time because Fred Smith the founder went
to Yale he started the Yale Aero Club
and I think he was a marine but he flew
he flew with the Navy I think in Vietnam
or at least during Vietnam and so we
were all but sure he'd be aware of the
story and indeed the story was something
that really meant something to him he
was also a member of skull and bones the
way probably five of these first unit
guys were as well and so in the end yeah
they came through with the last hundred
and fifty thousand dollars that we
needed to finish the film yeah I mean in
terms of the other little bit on
fundraising that all men
is that our fundraising was always
driven by necessity so it wasn't like we
were just trying to raise money randomly
for you know to say oh we would like to
raise you know twenty two hundred fifty
thousand dollars or something like that
never was like that it was always based
on necessity so we as we were developing
the script and we started editing we'd
realize there was a big chunk that we
needed to go somewhere to film or a
group of people that we needed to
interview and just and then we budget
for those particular parts of the film
so we yes we had an overall budget for
the film but as we went along over those
seven years we kind of did mini budgets
where we said oh we need to do that
particular suit how much does that
particular shoot gonna cost okay it's
gonna cost and we break it all down
travel whatever else was involved and
then and then we then our fundraising
efforts would drive toward fulfilling
that particular chunk so in the
newsletter we would say we need $25,000
to film a sopwith camel or we need
$20,000 for our composer right those
were two things that we really put out
there saying this is the next big thing
we need and you know we would be out of
money you know at each of each of these
stages yeah and this was a quarterly
newsletter you said that you uh it was
intended to be a quarterly newsletter
and most of the time it was quarterly
but uh a couple times it was off
schedule but generally it was a
quarterly yes so you this I find that
fascinating so you would weave in like
your own stories or different things and
then you also had information on what
was next for the final yeah as a matter
of fact the first thing that we did
before we even started fundraising
seriously was that we actually put our
website together first which was kind of
a little weird way of doing it you know
and what we did as part of our website
is we put up the imagery that we already
have
and we started to create kind of a
historical online museum as it were and
and the the website that we first put up
is actually still up there today but
that gave us kind of somewhere where our
potential contributors followers could
go and see you know what we were about
and what we were trying to do over time
and then as people got on the on the
email list that you know the there was
the added reach out reach with the
newsletter actually the very first thing
we did after we put together the
nonprofit organization and got our board
together which were friends of ours is
Ron and I put together a PowerPoint
presentation yeah what the story was and
they all fell asleep was this that like
some type of a mixers no is it my house
just you know here's the story and I
applied them with wine and you know well
now you work in IT right so they're you
know computer science so you've put
together the website or the first
iteration of the website I probably
sketched out we eventually did hire a
programmer to help us with it but as far
as my IT work I I did I was a computer
trainer for a number of years so I did
have a lot of background in that area so
I've been able to handle a lot of
technical stuff I'm not really working
in that field now but yeah I was for a
number of years well it helps so much to
have some you know I don't know if you
could do your own WordPress site or
whatever it was well that's half the
battle yes getting back but luckily I
mean just a side note on that is that
the tools have gotten so much easier to
use today than they were 15 years ago in
terms of putting up your own website I
mean like you said WordPress and there
are many other you know kind of
pre-formatted templated versions of
things that you can quickly do it when
we were doing the millionaires unit
website we they weren't quite to the
where they are today so that's why we
got a programmer involved but yeah the
budget was in the end million name and
it was a million dollars Fred ruse our
advisor we met with him early on and he
said so you're talking about a million
dollar picture I said oh no no no no I I
think three hundred three hundred fifty
thousand dollars and and I remember
think it'd be about two years maybe two
and a half years and but because of the
fundraising and because the movie kept
getting bigger it took us seven years
and in the end Fred was exactly right it
was a million dollars yeah I mean I
would think that our film for the budget
that we ended up spending on it was
probably a big bargain because you know
we did a lot of the shoots with very
very small crew like one in some cases
one person and and then when we did get
to New Zealand we were flying with
helicopters and airplanes and all of
that everybody who was involved in that
gave us lots of discounts so you know I
think it's more of a two million dollar
movie that got made for a million
dollars that's that's why I like to
think about it but in the end what did
that teach you about raising money for a
movie because I know looking back on at
seven years prior do you think you
actually would have said yes to it
knowing it wasn't just gonna be a few
years it wasn't just gonna be 300
thousand and all that's gone on what do
you think you would have said yes I I've
often wondered about that because it
would seem very daunting but but the
film grew in such an organic way and and
really we never flagged I mean that you
know there was some times that were
discouraging and sometimes we're just
out of money and nothing was really
happening but you know having a partner
passing the ball back and forth and I
was always interested in the next thing
we were going to do I mean and we
learned so much I had I had done
documentaries for television but I had
never done the whole thing soup-to-nuts
myself and from the research which I
really love and the right
to to actually shooting airplanes and I
went to Europe for five weeks and shot
there and went along the Western Front
and over the English Channel and then
just the movie just kept getting bigger
and bigger and more exciting and so
there'd be another hurdle and not enough
we always felt up for it yeah I mean my
sense throughout making the movie was it
was one of those ones of sort of focus
and also never taking really never
taking no for an answer it's sort of
like you have to be so dedicated that
you're you know people are telling you
no you can't do that you're never gonna
be able to do that and you basically in
your own mind and in your own spirit you
basically say yes I can do that and I'm
going to do that you know I mean so it's
one of those things of believing in the
project and that you will accomplish it
and finish it that was always there even
when we were at the low points that
Derek mentioned there's still this thing
that's saying this movie is going to get
completed we are going to finish it
we're gonna follow through and I think
that if filmmakers keep that sort of
mindset as they work on their films it
it will get you get you to where you
want to go you just have to believe that
it's going to happen and keep following
that vision and it is persistence it
really is just showing up I mean there
were times when Ron and I would fly to
New York you know to meet some people to
go to a dinner party and come back with
nothing and but you know the cumulative
effect of being there and going on and
you know having a bit to show for the
effort you put in you know finally pays
off and again as I as I said earlier the
film the film evolves you know and it
are often documentary filmmakers get
setbacks and they don't have the money
to edit or continue the film but that
time allows the story not only to grow
and maybe change but also to gestate and
then you come up with a much
fuller and richer Phil yeah yeah and the
other piece for young filmmakers or
other people starting out is I would
just say start making the movie it
doesn't matter
like if you have one picture and you're
making a documentary make a 30 second
video with that one picture with a
voiceover and maybe a little bit of
music behind it but demonstrate that you
can actually make something because
that's the thing that worked for us we
made little pieces of the movie over
time and we would show those pieces to
people and then people would finally say
oh oh you guys can actually make a movie
as opposed to just pitching an idea
because you don't have to have a lot of
resources to make a very simple piece
that will speak to your vision and what
you're trying to do you know so mate
start making the movie that's that's my
suggestion I completely agree with that
and there are two schools of thought
about that I've worked on other projects
where they said no we should we should
get all the money together first and you
know and then we won't be left hanging
and we'll we will know that we can do
this and and you know I think you have
to prove yourself I mean I don't know
Ken Burns doesn't have to or you know
very experienced filmmakers but you know
documentary films are curious individual
projects and they often don't work out
the way you've originally thought and so
yeah I think it's important to just
start working and sorry how far were you
into the process when you actually got
FedEx onboard as a sponsor FedEx the
story with FedEx is that we were six
years in Wow we got an invitation to
screen the film at Oshkosh which is the
largest air show in the United States
and we said yes to that even though we
didn't have a finished film and we
didn't have the finishing funds either
so this was this was one of those times
where we said yeah we'll be there we'll
have the movie we can screen it
then we were like okay how the heck are
we gonna do this let's call Fred Smith
that's when finally our fundraising team
broke down and said yes let's and we had
been trying to reach out to FedEx over
time but finally it broke through right
at the moment that we needed them and
they came in at the very last minute to
save us basically so that we could
finish the film for Oshkosh so again
showing up it sells like you were
planning to go there regardless yeah
even if you were going to show a little
trailer we made the commitment but yeah
just but they helped us out at the end